[Music]
Each drawing is made from hundreds if not thousands of letters, numbers, punctuation marks, all puzzle pieced together.
My name is James Cook.
I am atypewriter artist.
26 year old James Cook isan artist from Essex, England.
But he doesn't carry a sketchbook and pencils...
Instead he makes every one of his intricate drawings on a vintage typewriter.
I'll feed apaper through the machine probably eight to nine times
collaging and overlaying lots and
lots of information.
To recreate skin tones, I'll use the @ symbol because it has quite alarge surface area.
Brick work is underscores and capital I's to get the vertical lines.
Froma distance, it could quite easily be like a print or an illustration where it's only when theviewer gradually knees closer and closer tothe image
that all of these individual letters,
numbers and punctuation marks are revealed.
Everyone is drawn to peoples' eyes so that's thehardest facial feature to get right.
They have to be perfect.
Something else I will do to add another
layer of complexity to the drawings is conceal hidden words or phrases for the viewer to find.
How long does all this typing and tapping take?
Something that's A4 sized could take a week. There'sa picture of the London skyline that took two months.
How many key strokes is that?
Obviously I don't count how many.
I didactually try and download a piece of software which counted the number of times the hammershit the page
but it stopped working after fifty thousand, so I have no idea.
James' favoritetypewriters all have portable cases so he can pack them up and type outdoors.
People give a funny lookto begin with.
They'll be like - 'what's this guy doing with this typewriter on his lap? Why ishe writing a letter in the middle of London?'
But then as they edge closer, they suddenlyrealize 'oh no this, this is, he's making a drawing.'
And James' shelves are filling up.
I've gotabout 63 typewriters and counting, and I've been very lucky because the general publichave seen what I do with them.
They see it as a way of giving these machines a secondlife, otherwise they would be sitting aroundcollecting dust.
I've become a collector by
accident.
I didn't plan to have all of these.
They all have their own different personalities to them.
They all kind of work in different ways.
They have different sounds, a different feelingbehind the keys.
There's a lot of tap tap tap.
All these typewriters make a lot of noise.
There'ssome technology that will never die.
That's quite amazing to think that even though most peoplegenerally don't write with a typewriter anymore, they still have a purpose.
Is it fair to sayyou really love typewriters?
Uh, ooh, I'm not gonna, I'm not, I'm. Whoa.
Do I say yes to that?
Ilike drawing more than typewriters so...